انسى السلاحف المفاجئة ، هذه
سلحفاة صفعة ،
فلا عجب أن الفيديو انتشر
بسرعة وحصد ملايين المشاهدات ، هل كان هذان الشخصان
يشاهدان الكثير من تغطية الأوسكار ،
يبدو أن الصفع هو حقًا أه
في هذا الموسم ، يبدو أن
الممثل الكوميدي جيمي باباس في فيلادلفيا كان
يتجول  ملجأ هاينز للحياة البرية
عندما رصدت السلاحف التي بدت وكأنها
أشقاء صغار مثل صفعة تقاتل هذه
السلاحف ليست مجرد صفعة سعيدة ، ما
يدور في أذهانهم هو المداعبة التي
يقول خبراء الزواحف إنه موسم التكاثر في الربيع
وهذه
طقوس خفية تدغدغها من حولها
رأسها وعنقها وهو يستخدم
ملابسه ليثبت لها أنه سيكون رفيقًا ذا
نوعية جيدة وأن لديه مخالب لطيفة ،
نعم أن لديه مخالب طويلة لطيفة ومخالب طويلة
مهما كان يفعله يبدو أنه يعمل
، كانت تتبعه بالتأكيد.
وصف مستخدم تويتر الفيديو على أنه
لقطات فعلية لمحاولتي المغازلة
في الصف
الثامن ، نشر جيمي الكثير من مقاطع الفيديو الكوميدية
لكن هذا هو الذي اخترق
ما إذا انتهى بي الأمر بسبب مسيرتي المهنية
بأكملها لمداعبة السلاحف ، فقد غردت
البعض لم يستطع مقاومة إضافة مؤثرات صوتية ،
وهذا هو نوع من الحبال الذي يترك
حتى أنثى سلحفاة
صدمت
جنيموس صادمة.
يورك